[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Brian's right behind
or in front of me behind right the high
note has it taken exhale my spirit is
behind you spirit just gently massaging
your neck did another another good
episode man another good episode last
week was Martin Starr week before
Brandon Ralph or putting good content
out you know we're getting people you
know I'm doing my best to get guests
that people care about and more
importantly I think that if you listen
like let's say you're listening today
because you love this guess maybe you
might go back if you like this and go
hey you know I because I learned about
each guest and I think that each get
each the audience they agree listeners
go
you know I'm listening now even if I
don't know anybody yeah because you find
it because some people just you find
something yeah in each one that you're
like you might be able to relate to I
say teach time but you know I really
believe it did you do anything fun this
week and you're done with jury duty
thank God thank God I'll tell you all
about it he almost jumped off my roof it
wouldn't kill you it's not that high
good no but it's worth it for the
experience honestly like it cuz I've
been putting it off for so long and it's
easy to sort of you know put it aside
and just keep pushing and pushing it's
like they have finally done it
it's kind of a relief yeah I use my I've
had somebody back surgeries and stuff so
my doctor just says now he's not sitting
down for anytime anything like the time
god well I mean I'll give you the back
problems and neck problems and then I'll
switch which I rather be healthy and be
able to sit in a freaking chair for
hours although I'm doing it now big
shout out the patreon patrons on patreon
it's just another way to help the
podcast out and we appreciate it
you have no idea it's so nice to see oh
there's people just like going you know
and you get a lot of cool stuff there's
extra footage inside of me video that
you get every month some tears you get
to see the guests upcoming guests and
ask questions and merch packages and I
just love it I talk about its community
so that's cool
Wizard World June 5th coming up before
that May 9th we have Miami we're doing a
con Tom and I Smallville night so just
look at my Twitter and tweet her and all
that stuff so there you have that this
guest is she's been on before but she
wasn't filmed
and she made me cry she do you remember
that mm-hmm I mean a tear came down my
eye and I didn't address it
she just tells the story and she goes
are you crying I was like [ __ ] I it was
just she's such a great person I love
listening to her she has a great podcast
I was just on pajama pants she's an
extraordinary woman a great mom
a great wife she talks about her [ __ ]
though like you know she's not purred
we're not perfect so she talks about you
know raising kids she talks about you
know working with that math she talks
about things that again people aren't
always so open with and I like that that
you've enjoyed this one didn't you I did
yeah cuz I didn't know a lot about her
going into it I never watched The
Sopranos but she's just super sweet and
just a really nice story yeah and she's
dealing with a lot yeah I mean anyone by
anything
I think anytime you know we always think
our problems are so big and then me
sometimes see other people's problems
yeah you know it's not that your
problems are less it's just like I look
at her I'm like dude get the [ __ ] up and
do something get the [ __ ] up and
seriously she's got two kids she's
married she's working she has MS she's
doing a podcast it's like what the f
dude like you know what get up do you
have MS Ryan I don't okay neither do I
as far as I'm concerned so you know what
for Jamie for yourself yeah get up sorry
I don't know why I said that Jamie I
know you're listening I love you dearly
I just want to say for the record folks
you've seen Michael wear that shirt last
week well here's what happened we're
doing intros and outros for two episodes
I don't want to go up the stairs I'm
lazy to get another shirt on that's
probably similar to this shirt wear the
same clothes every day sorry I will just
do the Farley every episode all right
let's get inside jamie-lynn Sigler it's
my part of you
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you look great I'm not just saying that
you do you do look great thank you
that's very nice I've always that's such
an awkward thing to received to say
don't ever say you look great again to
me I'm just like what do I say back you
know you say what thank you thank you
that's it okay I'm not good at receiving
compliments well that's something like I
I've talked about it before but like
don't you think it's it's just better if
there's an understanding like if I say
hey I like your shirt instead of going
it's an old shirt I don't know because
maybe we don't believe the person
because we have so many compliments and
I don't think that they're real it's
Hollywood it's great but anything that's
all over the world it's like people go
oh my god you look great and they're
like no I didn't sleep like yesterday I
was drunk I don't we're afraid to share
our like happiness where she were afraid
to share like we were afraid to be
judged by our reaction like if I
would've been like yeah I felt good
walking out the house today
you'd be like oh she's a little bit of a
[ __ ] she talked she agreed yeah I said
hey you look like you're having a good
day she was actually a really high what
a [ __ ] that's what I'm afraid of
do you think maybe when someone says it
that I don't know is it an insecurity is
it just like you feel better if it's
self-deprecating like you're you're
being I feel more relatable if I'm
self-deprecating right it's weird you
find community and like common ground in
like the shitty [ __ ] you don't come
together for the joy or we come together
for our sorrows that's true so so sort
of writing the stuff I got you know
Jamie I mean you know yeah I don't know
you you look tired are you tired you
know a cab just so tired got roses mum
you look like [ __ ]
ah I feel like [ __ ] and then we're just
drowning in our own misery my nanny
loves to tell me when I look tired I
don't like when people that's that I
don't mind it when she does cuz I'll be
like yeah that's why I need you do you
know what I think looking tired I think
people may make the mistake
when they say you look tired I then
immediately go god man
I can't I don't want to look at myself
in the mirror I look like [ __ ] what you
know you're really bad when somebody
points it out that you looked at you
know what I think it is what I don't
think they're saying you look tired like
your appearance like your face looks
tired your eyes your face is your smile
is tired the cheeks are tired your skin
is tired I think they're looking at you
and they're going you disposition you're
catching your value like this watch if
I'm gonna like this you know I'm like
Jamie I've had a great frickin week I
probably don't look tired right
no but if I was like this is like yeah
so how's everything all in your energy
so when they say you've seen guys maybe
they should change it up maybe they
should say Ryan yeah you look good but
you seem tired yes cuz I don't want to
hear I look tired no I don't know if I
like that either though
yes you look good but you seem like a
piece of [ __ ] you seem like a piece of
[ __ ] you know what yeah I get that it's
almost like God you know you you look
like you're on cocaine your body's
moving around a lot that's what this is
just horrible you're saying I look like
I'm on meth is what it looks like yeah
that's what the fun part about kids is
is they just they just they don't care
about a repercussions a totally live in
honesty and truth and that's it so what
are you here what's the worst thing
you've ever heard from your kid did they
ever say things like there's someone
around you they go he's fat you know my
I've heard my son since he started like
being in elementary school like dropping
things like that like that person's fat
or this sucks and I'm like hey yeah you
don't say that dude and the husband's
laughing about it is okay that's the
problem is sometimes like there's
laughter that follows it because they're
so cute and you know they don't know
what they're saying but like this is I
think that's your true job as a parent
it's just give them a moral compass
like understand how to not hurt people's
feelings other than that I really don't
have much influence he is who he is
do they tell you look tired yeah oh my
god he'll tell me every you don't look
good I don't like your hair like that
um take that makeup off that shirt looks
funny yeah yeah constructive criticism I
really accept well like oh it doesn't
okay
I don't know how I had a response I
don't know people would say you'd make a
great parent because I think I'm not
sure but I think I would I would fire
back like most people mature adults
they've you know the kid of like that
sweater looks ugly I'm like yeah well
you can't even read throw me some [ __ ]
you just another Rosenbaum what I would
do and I do with my friends is I I'm
affectionate I think although I did that
test that um love language but it's a
test you take and you can find out yeah
you know what you who you are what your
love language is so I think mine was
quality time get ready for this um
affectionate right was last like like
like being touched I guess you just gave
such a good hug when I got here I think
I am affectionate when I feel
comfortable when I feel like it's really
authentic and that's when you should
know by 10:00 at most the time if I'm
not in a relationship or if I'm just
talk seeing someone I don't want to give
them too much to make them lead them on
unless I know I'm in it I don't think
that's a bad thing I know but it's
intimacy it's a fear of intimacy is what
it is
that's not good I'm working on that
that's okay you don't want to you don't
want to mislead anybody know the quality
time is number one time is number one
absolutely a giver not even on my radar
you don't like giving I know I love
giving gifts but like receiving gifts I
I could give two should me - I don't
want to receive them I want to give them
I love giving I give more than I get I
don't and you know what it's number two
I think was words of affirmation just
like Ryan mm-hmm
you look really handsome today I like
that better than the other thing you
said was that you look like [ __ ]
yeah well you're sure is that blue from
colorblind that blue shirt really does
something with your dark eyes I don't
know what it does but it you look really
good there's something positive I'm I
would be the best husband if that's what
women want it because I'm genuine like
your hair
I am media if I don't see someone for
weeks I go you did something with your
hair I'm like yeah and every boyfriend
our husbands give me like you [ __ ] yes
sorry I just noticed those things I
don't know why yeah maybe I'm a
hairdresser a secret when I discover
this every time that we would have made
a really good couple that's that's what
I like I like receiving Ephram of
affirmation see that would work as I
like to do that and I'm genuine about it
I would always be like how he looks like
when I walked in yeah I'm surprised you
look this good
really why cuz I have two kids I think
it's everything you've been through hell
you work all the time you're married you
have two kids you have MS yeah I mean
these things can I don't have MS and I
feel like [ __ ] so I mean I could easily
look like [ __ ] and you you're radiant
I'm sure you fight things all the time
god I had a terrible morning what
happened I just my six-year-old is just
really hard why when he's great he's
[ __ ] great but when he's not great
it's just so annoying and like yesterday
I took him to hockey and I'm watching
him and all he's doing is checking kids
like he's like no checking no trucking
on the ice Jack there's a cross-check
which is illegal there's a hip check we
the hip goes is doing all a back check
that yep and I texted my husband and I'm
like yo we've I think we might have the
kid that like I hate like people don't
like like I'm worried that he's annoying
and to other people and like I don't
like that this is his instinct and it's
like it's a real issue as a parent
because obviously I think my kids the
greatest but then you're also seeing the
side of him and were like ah and it's
nothing anyone did it's we
he's figuring life out and then I feel
bad like also talking [ __ ] about my kid
but like and he really like everything's
a fight like go eat breakfast go brush
your teeth no I literally looked at him
this morning I was like beau just know
this cuz then he's good by the end of
the day he's like you know cuz he got
the Xbox taken away and the iPad taken
away yesterday and he's like I hear him
in the shower being like I hate myself I
don't belong in this family and like
part of me is like okay that's for show
but then another part of me is like oh
[ __ ] do I need to pay attention to these
words and make sure these aren't they
yeah he wants attention
yes so this morning I said Tim I was
like look Bo I'm sure you and I are
gonna get in a fight today I'm sure I'm
gonna yell and I'm gonna feel bad about
it I'm sure you're gonna do something
misbehave and then you're gonna get
reprimanded just know this no matter
what I think you're the greatest and I
love you mmm just remember that you know
he's like I'm looking like everywhere
but me and I'm like look me in the eye
dude tell me you heard me he's like I
did I love you and then the rest of the
morning it's just that [ __ ] like and
then he's VIP at school this week so
they get to like bring things in and so
he wants to bring his hockey bag with
all his goalie gear burritos Cheetos
actually oh whatever I'm like bo you
can't bring like all your hockey gear
into school like the whole huge of the
he could fit in his hockey bag it's like
enormous and just the fight this morning
and I just started crying because I was
like cuz I also have a two-year-old
who's like demands
olá and he's obsessed with me which I
love but it demands a lot of my time and
attention right I also am a wife I also
have a career I also have MS like you
said like I've got a lot I have a lot of
role does he do that my way what does bo
do when he sees you cry on his knees
holding my face telling me he loves me
so sad so that's the trigger he needs to
see that you're really hurting that he's
really upset you before he could just
kind of take it easier yeah so he's
pushing every button until he goes ah I
got her so there there's some psychology
there he knows that you know I'm gonna
go
and when she starts crying then I'm baby
be good I try not to but like today I
lost it I see he was rattled by it was
it a good cry no he was just more like a
hat like just my head down in my hands
and like I could feel him like hovering
over me and he's like tap music are you
crying and I'm like yes dude like happy
is too much how hard is he yes I'm
crying because I'm [ __ ] you I didn't
say I know I know I was how we do it but
I'm sure Sam that would come out of me
every once in a while you know if I'd go
that's Farley Samuel would be like yeah
it's something we could have talked
about right but you said something I'm
gonna read one because I was trying like
states stay focused in what she's saying
I want to hear it but also I'm gonna go
back about three and a half minutes you
said that I I don't know do I have the
annoying kid yes is it you I have been
around parents that I'm like
are you [ __ ] blind and deaf that you
can't see what a monster your [ __ ]
kid is like I've had him in my house and
I thought dude it I had a kid in my
house once yeah I mean with their other
families that sounds weird I had a kid
in my house once a lion's like what no
not like that you know I'm fun time yeah
I know there's a kid over with this bomb
or something and the kid has a once you
say a an app for [ __ ] [ __ ] up
Oh any done and I think he doesn't a
purpose mm-hmm and I happen to be behind
this kid one time while he was walking
around my house I just happen to be
walking behind him at the time I was
like I wasn't following the child the
same idea I had this Lord of the Rings
chess set don't ask me why but I have it
Nancy and they just stop for a second
when he looked over to it and he just
backhanded hey he turned around I go
what the heck was that about man
he's like I don't dude look you don't
knock people stuff over you don't do
that stuff yeah all right you don't do
that in someone else's house I'm sure
you don't do in your own house that's
not cool
nobody likes that kid all right I like
you you're a good kid but right now that
kind of crap people aren't gonna like
you so don't do that something like that
parent he just like this you know that
loved it yeah you know but I wanted to
make sure you did like it was they were
there did they notice that he was doing
this shouldn't say anything cuz that's
my issue I don't like when parents are
so into like being around other adults
like trust me I get it when it's like a
reprieve but like also be responsible
for your kid like my husband and I that
I'm very grateful cutter and I are like
super on top of our kids Jack very aware
I'm a thank you when you gave that to
him like I'm I'm that much good I screw
in him because I know he hears it I know
it'll click one day like I know
and let me say this bow is his worst at
home when he's with other people and
other adults he's great and I think I
guess I would rather it be that way than
him being like you know addicted Xand
other bullying no I no not at all he's
really kind to other kids to the point
where he gets upset he won't watch the
Sandlot anymore or Mighty Ducks because
he doesn't like when kids are being mean
to other kids that's nice that's a good
thing because if he's liking things like
that and animals being killed and that's
that's on your way to being a surrogate
a serial killer yeah I think it's
important I mean to show the love I love
you but there's also like I think that
again I'm not a father and everybody
listening is probably be like do you
don't know you're talking about but I'm
just telling you what I would do
theoretically theoretically if my kid we
went to another house and I saw him
doing stuff I would tell him before we
got there I don't you have a great time
you know what you'd enjoy yourself but
I'm telling you right now if you do
something and I say stop and you
continue on or you break something you
knock something that we're just going
there's not gonna be no dad please
you're gonna start crying and be upset
but we're going and the only you're only
gonna learn if I do that if I put my
foot down and we leave the party I'm
upset because we had to leave you're
upset and the next time we go to a party
maybe your dumb ass won't do it again
and that's how I feel burying with love
I love you I'm proud of you
you'll never be stupid in my eyes just
be honest be the best you can be you
know things I didn't hear but you know
these things are important but also like
you know my friend Chris was telling me
once he's like man these kids nowadays
nobody smacks something orgasmic smack
on the answer you can't talk about that
[ __ ] hey man my dad busted my ass and
he's like yeah my dad busted my ass
every once in a while I might say and
you know what I didn't do [ __ ] again no
smack on the ass and people don't talk
about it now I got paddled in school no
that's bad because that's embarrassing I
got spanked in it for sure yeah
I think most kids our generation did
what are you 38 yeah
yeah did you research me or something
yes I'm 38 but yeah no but no you can't
do that now you can't have another kids
kid adults good you know it's like you
can coach Bo I bet you'd like Bo I play
hockey so I can dude you'd love it
like he would like he has whenever my
husband goes out of town or I go out of
town like - you know for us to feel
better about our guilt of being away he
gets a new jersey so he's has 17 hockey
jerseys right now his little collection
may be a good one oh that's are you
gonna I'll tell you what team he doesn't
have what I don't know I have to look I
go through his closet San Jose Sharks
burnsy
it's one of my good buddy he doesn't
have charms I mean I'm not saying he's
like sign he has like ones that he wears
okay rangerous he has he has three
Rangers ones all right so listen why
don't know while you've been away cuz
it's been a while yeah you have you've
been working a lot I actually quit
acting in between though I quit acting
for a year you quit acting when you're
having the second child Jack that's when
you quit but you've been going on lately
right I just started back again in the
summer now how hard is that with a
family and dealing with that mass and
getting cast and people knowing the
situation going can I do this and the
studio's going can Jamie do this can she
get through the scenes can she are they
patient or people nice or they how does
that even work it's hard enough to get
an acting job fair sure but when you
have something that you're like well
this is part of me yeah you know what do
you do I'm still grappling with like
walking into an audition room like
owning it do you know what I mean
because it's out there people know it is
what it is thank God because yours is so
open and that's importantly so we're
only the past couple of years I mean I
wasn't for a long time well let me take
it back so first I quit acting because I
kind of just needed to give myself a
chance to see if I gave a [ __ ] anymore
about it you know sometimes you can get
in the grind and like the hamster wheel
of it and you're like
we liked I know I love it when I'm doing
it but I don't love the getting the job
part like I don't love auditioning I
don't love the stress of it all like and
I was just like you know I got two kids
I have a lot on my plate like I need to
really see if I love this I'm gonna step
away from it for a little while and I
thought that my reps were gonna be like
so supportive because a lot of the times
I think and it's my own thing I guess
but I just assume that people still want
to work with me because I'm nice and
like they love me but not because of
money value of like my talent or
anything
see software from the same [ __ ] we all
do like we're not good enough but they
like me of course you're good enough
well when I had my manager I thought I
truly thought my manager is gonna be
like I support this Jame I love you you
didn't support you he was like [ __ ] no
you're not quitting I'm gonna give you a
few weeks and then you're gonna call me
and I was like but I get but it was a
year and he kept calling and he kept
calling and I was like not yet not yet
and I had this moment where I was
sitting on the floor with my kids and it
was like a nice moment everyone was
playing nicely like nothing was wrong
and it was like my breath got taken away
and I was like ah I am not cut out to be
a stay-at-home mom like there is I have
to honor that there's like other [ __ ] I
still want to do like holy [ __ ]
so I went back to acting class cuz I
wanted to see I'm like okay I had that
moment but like I want to get back in
this grind and like see acting class so
you didn't jump back into auditioning
back wait a minute
which I haven't been in in I don't feel
like I think class would be even scarier
beyond everybody's 20 and amazingly
gorgeous and just moved to LA and like
you know and then it happens in an
acting class because it's been a while
since I've been an activist but do you
like to give you scenes you have to
memorize them is that hard to do since
you hadn't done it in a year so how long
did it take you I mean I do it during
naps or like you know when the kids went
to bed and I took it super seriously and
I I loved that I wasn't great at first
like I was a little rusty and I like I
see these kids in there that like shut
down when they start getting like
direction or or redirection like these
literally these young kids are like
they're like hmm hmm but me I'm like
uh-huh uh-huh okay yeah I'll do it that
way oh yeah you're right I do do that
like I love being dissected because how
long did you do this for I'm still in it
how long has this been almost year in
April I went back into acting class and
then I got my first job in June and then
I worked straight from June all the way
till now I did this really fun lay and
everything was offered I don't know what
happened with the universe because I
told you like I [ __ ] hate auditioning
and I can't remember the last time to be
honest I've books anything from an
audition but everything it just kept
coming in like I did a little movie and
then I did this sitcom for Adult Swim
with Tim and Eric
the comedian yeah had a great time
during doing that Tim and Eric ago I
knew you would no no I was just
listening and I just know I didn't know
you needed me to go I do know them okay
yeah I do yeah I did a bunch of Indies I
did a TV movie and then I did another
one in the night I finished the year in
December I literally work back to back
to back to back which was kind of insane
to go from like not working at all -
like not stopped working but there's
almost what I needed to get back in the
swing of things and understand that like
my kids still love me they don't feel
neglected I hate the word balance but I
can do both and then the last thing I
did was the short film in December and
it was the most gratifying acting
experience of my entire life and it
wasn't it's the short film called
I'm on fire with this director Michael
Smith yeah and it was like just [ __ ]
gritty I've never done a short before
where it took 12 days to shoot 12
minutes like if you think about like the
the detail that was shot and it was
amazing did you have done that without
the acting class sure I could have done
it maybe not as well you wouldn't been
as good you learn your lines as fast as
your mouth knows it I think it's just
more of like feeling rooted and like I
don't know I'm come from the school of
like I don't I don't feel comfortable
getting something unless I worked for it
so it feels like I'm like doing my work
so it I feel like I belong there more
not only that but I think you know
whether you're an actor or not but like
it's almost like they women you get
hired just let's just hire Michael
Rosenbaum or let's hire jamie-lynn
Sigler and you get hired you almost like
I don't know exactly what they want me
to do right and so then you're hired and
then all of a sudden you're doing it and
if you've had auditioned and got it then
they're like oh you're like well
whatever I did that's what they want so
I'm just gonna do that it's kind of
weird like I hear you guys want this I
don't exactly know what you wanted am i
doing it right either so there could be
like that yes and then to also reference
like the whole MS conversation of it all
in order for me to feel comfortable I
have to have like the same conversation
with everyone I'm about to work with
which is like here's my limitations
what are they can't run high heels are
hard walking long distances I'm gonna
start to limp so like you know keeping
the shots shorter mornings are better no
no I have full energy like fortunately
it doesn't affect me cognitively energy
wise not everything's just kind of like
the waist down and it's just more it
gets tired but if I sit and rest and I
always tell if I need anything I've
never ever needed a break I've never
told anyone I needed a break because I'm
not trying to like be a superhero I just
have it and then directors and people
are willing to work around it so I've
been very fortunate you know I I still
feel like a burden and I still feel bad
that I have to have that conversation
and I'm comforted every time and being
like please Jamie everybody has
something like this is no big deal we
can figure this out that's not you know
it sounds you're really strong because I
wish I could have these conversations
about my own things beforehand so like
hey listen their insecurities about
myself and like you know if I found this
or if I matter you know I'm gonna be
nice to do that hey listen man yeah you
never get hired like what this guy's
nervous he gets anxiety attacks it's
like
any of those that's good maybe because
all of my energy is channeled in
focusing on my physicality of everything
you ever notice it do you ever notice
things when you're watching pick it
apart all the time like you like that
walk right there that's because of the
MS and I hate it which is why I don't
watch myself around them can you go to a
close-up or can you cut in no I've never
gotten the balls to do that I always
assume that they're gonna do what looks
best and they trust them but I mean I
catch it and it's a bummer it's and
sometimes it's like you know I can feel
like I'm doing great and like there's
still something there and it's uh it's
like I don't know it's a reality check
it's it's it's it's not the most fun for
me you know because I also you know when
I'm not working and momming like all of
my hours sitting here with you I'm you
know like really heavily focused on
fighting this all the time and trying to
get as well as I can and and you know
like right now what we're talking are
you fighting it no I'm relaxed you are
there's nothing about you right now that
you're feeling like nothing there's
nothing abnormal no and you take
medications twice a year and then I have
lice a year but like an intravenous
chemotherapy twice a year and it's like
an immunosuppressant it's well the only
MS meds that are really out there are
ones that suppress the disease so slow
it down
I've been stable for over nine years
with no changes and no changes I feel
confident working to because it's not I
tell them like it's not like I'm gonna
wake up one day and like not be able to
move or this or that like that my MS is
not bad right
sometimes I wish it was relapse
remitting so I could have really great
days and then be like oh this is bad day
but I guess if I had to choose it would
normal Social Work is like this is how
it is because then I guess that is more
of a crapshoot
yeah but what about like you know our
friend summer Blaire she's in a
different level she has a very different
disease than me is that I mean it's hers
is relapse remitting but hers affects
her like so many different ways so it's
it's heartbreaking different levels of
this disease it's not just everybody
who has it has the same thing that all
everybody has the same so people could
live long they live short big you know
mm-hmm that's just the way it is and so
you have you ever thought of like why
should i watch myself I'm gonna do the
best work I can because you kind of want
to see yourself and see the work you did
I boast of the time don't watch myself
did you use to no actually yeah I mean I
should - what no I've never actually
never I've only seen the first season of
Sopranos and then the first episode of
every season in the last very last
episode I think I just get up well
that's because I got MS closely after
not that I was symptomatic at all but I
think it's just it just got in my head
and I just also to like I like in class
like I love somebody else picking apart
my acting but has perspective but I just
feel like I don't have proper
perspective on myself right why I put my
side much rather watch like Vanderpump
rules then yeah I commend you I mean
without a choice you don't feel like I
have I don't feel like I don't feel like
I need like a pause for the way I do
things you know what I mean like I just
feel like I truly feel like if anyone
was in my position they would do the
same things as me I do I'd like to
believe that because hey I have kids B I
have dreams and like I'm 38 like I don't
want to throw it all in right you know I
just I don't know I could I tried it and
you told you I sat in the portals like
[ __ ] no I can't do it
I bet it was when you first got
diagnosed in all this and you're going
through you're probably they're probably
a lot of days you're like [ __ ] it I
don't want to do anything I'm just I
could I have every right to I have every
excuse in the book I think that's what
I've become very conscious of lately was
like I am done allowing MS to be an
excuse like I it's it's a very easy have
I use it like out of sex and things like
that for sure but like wait what you
don't like in times when my husband's
like hey and I'm like a campy I'm so
tired my legs hurt like mine you just
say MS say to my husband MS
I just want to add from ms so you just
keep with letters I want to have MS
sweetie
I guess I good MS NF I choose not to do
that because it's way too easy
and I don't I told you I like to work
for things so it's that's the easy route
I mean I think it's with with anything
else I mean if like he's probably I
don't know if this analogy is gonna work
Ryan dry I whenever I look at Ronnie I
always know something's not going to
work
don't cut it out if it doesn't yeah well
like depression like anxiety yeah I
don't know I think that if you let it
get the best of you if you're just like
I give up I'm just gonna let this
anxiety ruin my life and I'm gonna let
this depression take over and I'm not
gonna get help and I'm not going to
exercise and I see like MS obviously MS
you can't get rid of mmm but you could
control something you couldn't at least
be the best version of yourself you
could feel the best that you can feel by
doing the things that you know will help
or the things because rolling over and
just saying [ __ ] it you're gonna
deteriorate if you just didn't exercise
and you didn't do this mentally this
would debilitate you more and the
disease would become more pressure right
so I think that's the same thing with
depression yeah you don't go see a
doctor you don't you know if you're
drinking caffeine at 11 o'clock at night
you're gonna these anxiety is gonna take
over I've seen this happen with me right
so it's a man you don't let yourself
feel though like I definitely let myself
have days where I'm like this [ __ ]
sucks I'm sad I'm angry you just cry
sometimes oh yes I have to do I'd
explode inside of you is brought to you
by Squarespace
Squarespace that's right I know
Squarespace it's just you know I'm not
you're a little more creative than I am
we've talked about this but you know I
come you are come on
well especially in the art world no like
drawing art no I'm talking about like
creating a beautiful website you could
probably do that well I mean with it
with the proper template and everything
I could do I don't even know what a
template is outline turn your cool idea
into a new website showcase your work
how many people have these ideas and
they're like I don't
what to do and then the idea all of a
sudden you see somebody else two months
later and they get the idea and they do
it they get well you know what they did
they go to Squarespace and they figure
it out
blog or publish content sell products
and services of all kinds to promote
your physical or online business
announced an upcoming event or special
product and more what I like is
Squarespace does pretty much everything
for you in so many ways they give you
these beautiful as you say templates
created by world-class designers
powerful ecommerce functionality lets
you sell anything online customize the
look the feel settings and more with
just a few clicks
built in search engine optimization free
and secure hosting 24/7 award-winning
customer support nothing to patch or
upgrade ever make it yourself easily
create a website by yourself make it
standout doesn't make it so stand out
with a beautiful website that's all so
you have to do head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code iou to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain at squarespace.com enter code
I owe you you know it's funny I'm about
to go do something called EMDR have you
ever heard this week EMDR it's like app
rapid eye movement it's so you know
everybody who listens to me knows I went
to a well in the center like last year I
know if you knew yeah I just wanted to
feel better and get better and all these
things and you know I had some I think
what happens is a lot of people have
traumas and they don't know what they
don't really know how severe they are
for instance when I heard about EMDR I
heard oh they give this to vets right
people who fought in wars and have seen
the worst things that none of us could
even imagine and I think oh well it's it
works for them because that's real
trauma my trauma is not real your trauma
is a it can't be that's what I thought
it was a respect thing there's like no
these soldiers died they see death all
around them and what the therapist was
trying to tell me was like stop
we're trying to make you better and you
probably had some trauma and if you did
we'll get to the bottom of met at bottom
of it and so I was in this room and I
said I want to try this EMDR I don't
feel like I don't know it just it's not
right for me it's for vets and she's
like we start talking dirty vets and
Jamie that's in here
well she starts talking to me and she
goes I know what about the EMDR she was
oh yeah we're not gonna do that and I go
yeah yeah I'm not right for that so yeah
I get it
and then we start talking about stuff
and in the next session you know and I
go yeah so we're not gonna get into the
EMDR stuff I mean why would we Amanda
there's nothing here I'm telling her
she's like yeah yeah we're not gonna
like yeah think so and then we start
talking and then she goes I'm just
talking about a moment and like I was
talking to you I suddenly went and then
I was just like boom and then this
happened I don't want to say it but like
yeah and and it's not that that's bad
it's just I don't want to call anybody
out but you know I just had this moment
where I just it was visceral it was the
I mean I could see it and if you're
looking at me telling the story I'm like
and I'm just this little boy and I was
just like you know and then they go and
then and then she goes
I think you're ready and I go for what
she I said do you want to do this I go
but uh well she is that that moment you
just had right there I'd like to explore
that I go no I don't even know what to
do just a us for your stop you don't
have to control everything you don't
have to do this is just just try this
like okay and she came over to me she's
so sweet and so calm and she goes I want
you to close your eyes and I want you to
think of this moment and I just want you
stay in this moment think of it and when
you open your eyes my finger is gonna go
like this
don't turn your head with it I want you
to just with your eyes back and forth
and you just follow my finger and you
think of that moment I'll walk you
through it and I said okay so I close my
eyes and she goes okay I want you to go
back there and I took as long as I
needed and in feel like I was rushed
like I show up my eyes now she's
probably ready for me to do this you
don't man and I opened them and she goes
okay I just follow my finger
stay in that moment and I'll do I'm
telling you I went from I don't know - I
- hysterical like overwhelming emotion
came over me I couldn't I almost makes
me emotional thinking about it because
of how emotional I was like she is are
you okay oh yeah no no this this feels
good I feel like I just I don't know she
was okay close your eyes and we did it
again and we eat it again and like four
or five times and I'm not telling you
where you can go I'm saying don't
control your mind when you do it but I
ended up at a place where that moment
it's not that that moment was just gone
right it's not that that moment was
wasn't real or it was as though which he
says it sometimes it's like you knocked
down a tree it's like this big tree that
you're knocking down and all these other
little emotions that will play into that
emotion so for instance if it was some
kind of abuse or some kind of like big
lot whatever it was death if you've had
other moments in your life
even though you didn't talk about those
moments it's almost like little trees
start to fall down because when you get
to the root of what the problem is a lot
of that those things
you let you're able to let go and what
happens is and I didn't know this she
goes I don't want you just think of that
moment again close your eyes think of
that moment boom boom boom boom boom
boom and I go it's just I go I'm sorry
she doesn't what I go I just
really I can't get there just you can't
get there I go no it's I don't know it's
like I know that moments there but I
can't get to that moment like I can't
and what I found was as the days went on
even now whenever I think of that moment
if I try to which I don't but if I try I
know it's there
but it's like it doesn't affect me like
that anymore it just doesn't it's
science
it [ __ ] works I know you've read
about it yeah and people who have had
trauma yeah I think if you're willing to
talk about it and fine and by the way
this was this wasn't like this is the
moment I want to work on right this was
out of the blue a moment we were talking
I just got this
she has let's talk about that I know
that oh no that couldn't have effect oh
my god did that affect me as a kid cool
so all I say is be open and may not work
right away you may not do it right away
but I feel like you're an open person
you've been through so much that I feel
like you're gonna get to you're gonna
see I was gonna say that I have like I
feel like you know me well you had
probably one of the last things you
would describe me as as an angry person
right angry I don't see was angry at all
I have so much anger inside of me and I
don't know why and that's what like led
me into finding EMDR and like finding a
vetted person that I'm gonna start with
next week because I'm like what the [ __ ]
is this anger and obviously I do all
this type of reading on disease and like
the emotional components of it and the
causes the root causes because you know
some people believe that disease is
manifested from trauma and emotions that
are help stuck in your body oh an anger
shame and guilt are associated with MS
and those are three things that I deal
with and I don't know why so after next
week and we'll see from the posted I
wanna know watch I'm gonna be like
running marathons at the MBI you know I
remember when I was doing the MDR there
was one of those sessions where it was
only one session that I really the other
ones I forced I tried to get back there
yeah what I needed to do was let that
moment take over and go and that was
enough and I'd like to do it again when
I'm ready I'd like to do and I think
there are there's a lot of things that
ice there that need to be taken care of
that need to be let I don't know yeah
but I remember there was one thing I was
like is I you know I remember going well
because I'm not a [ __ ] idiot I was
like like yelling not yelling and
screaming I was like course
[ __ ] smart of course on this how
could I possibly I was almost validating
myself like of course how could you be
successful like this how could you do
this if you want do you think you're
that stupid like I'm almost telling this
little boy that you're not you're all
these things that you're not how could
you have gone on and done all these
things being dumb and being like all
these and it was crazy I was like it was
truly because I know it's it's sad it's
sad but it's also like these are the
things you have to like you have to face
these things because if you don't face
them if you don't get them out then
what's the point then you're living the
rest of your life and you're not being
the best you when I had my like pre call
with a therapist she was like that
pre-cum serious to pre-cum she was
telling me she's like you know when you
see adults have road rage or their
reactive that's not the adult in them
reacting it's the child so healing that
trauma heals behavior that you have now
that you just feel like is just you know
sorry I just have road rage or I just
have this or I have that you know you
don't have to have that that's something
that was learned or something something
happened to you that I got it from
watching watching my dad watching my
older brother watching them on the road
you know I just remember my dad driving
it's me you know screaming like you've
seen this as a cutter has it for sure
his dad at it I mean cause I mean
there's oh my god Lenny Dykstra [ __ ]
Jill no no we don't have contact with
Lenny right now but he I sometimes I'm
like I'll catch a tweet or two and I saw
something where he was like it's been
something amount of months since I've
been arrested so it's amazing man cuz
that guy was like everybody's hero you
know yeah and I maybe he needs EMDR
maybe he needs a lot of things that you
know he's mad act when I first met Lenny
I do we talked about this and now people
are probably listening and watching
because you know right well I first met
him right before he went into jail it's
when cutter and I first started dating
like three weeks into dating and his dad
went
unexpectedly to jail he thought he's
going for a court date and literally was
cuffed and sent to jail that day
she's a very dark moment to go through
with like your new beau you know and so
then he was in jail for about a year and
a half when he came out we had a son and
uh he was wonderful
I loved sitting and talking with him I
loved hearing him talk about baseball of
cutter and just he was reserved and kind
and a good listener and then you know
just life happens and like certain
habits start to come back and I think
when you know the persona of nails and
what people want and he's trying to give
people what they want but live this life
and I think it just kind of caught up
and then I saw kind of him change and it
was a bummer but I still think of that's
who I met is who Lenny is it's the ocean
that changes him yeah I will never say a
bad thing about him I think it's the
right choice right now for a lecture us
not to have contact but I do if my kids
ever ask me about who their grandpa is
I'll say he was great yeah you saw the
real side mm-hmm you know and a lot of
times it is a persona and it's something
that you like this is what they want to
see or this is what I'm so used to
playing that the vulnerable side just
seems the armored [ __ ] I can't do this
I can't talk about that like I just want
to be you know talkies my label people
good people or bad people and I just
think that's [ __ ] up I think everybody
is light and dark everybody is good and
bad everyone just has choices and
everybody has weaknesses and sometimes
the other side wins or the other side
loses you know he some of us are not
strong enough to fight those how hard is
it though I have to imagine I can't even
imagine what cutter goes through it's
it's hard it's sad I mean I mean I had
to be tough it had to be tough I always
had it was something that was
significant enough that he had to draw
the line and it was really sad for him
and really sad for me and it was almost
like he had to like mourn his dad do you
know what I mean it was almost like was
he scared of his father I'm sure there
was some level of that I mean he's an
intimidating guy and like especially
when it was like come to talk around
like bass
on this yeah I mean I'm sure Lenny
especially I think in the darker days
where Lenny like wasn't sleeping and
when they lost their fortune I think
that was like a very scary time for the
family Jesus yeah it's crazy talking
about this stuff it is like man I still
don't see you with it you know it's
funny you say you have this anger issues
that's like this if you wind up ten no
one knows it when I'm acting it's like
my first choice that I want to use is
like anger so I know it's simmering in
there by the way it's funny you say that
because you'll never see me lose my [ __ ]
but when you keep my brother wants Eric
by the way my brother is always has my
back the nicest he was in our teammates
yeah Eric's great um
but once I'm in the van and I was really
hungry and that's one thing when I'm
hungry I just gotta eat yeah so if I
tell you Jamie
we should eat probably in half an hour
you cool with that I'm hungry
yeah and even if you're not hungry go
yeah if you're hungry you should eat I
know you right and then it's an hour and
then it's an hour and a half now my
brother it wasn't even that it was time
it was he was so defiant I remember
specifically he's driving and I'm in the
backseat hey dude we just stopped at a
jack-in-the-box man I'm just gonna get a
quick spicy chicken Jack and some fries
come curlies and he's like no huh just
dismissive and I go I go you serious no
man I'm really hungry I thought he's
kidding I go God you know I'm really
hungry so just late you know we gotta
get in the road man I go I know I dude
I'm really hungry and it kept going like
he was listening he's like he passed it
got on the road I go dude I told you I
want to get something to eat and he's
just like yeah well we're not gonna do
that right now and dude the next thing
you know there is a football for some
reason there's a football in the van and
it just goes right by his head I try I
tried to [ __ ] hit him
I was Joe Montana I would have [ __ ]
popped him in his [ __ ] head but I
mean if somebody pushes your buttons
will you [ __ ] move when cutter will
not stop like harping like he can keep
gets on things and they doesn't stop I
lose show me your [ __ ] show me your
temper
I can't is it scary no it's not scary
it's almost funny it's almost like
comical I think when I get angry people
laugh because I look ridiculous like I'm
not somebody that's like a good angry
I'm like I get like very rigid and like
I'm like yes why is this happen like
yeah like we were fighting last night
about something and I was like and he he
he realized I was right and he I was
looking at him being like so can you
apologize and he was staring the TV
being like I'm sorry okay I'm sorry I
was like no he's like I said I'm sorry
what more you want I was like if you
don't look at me and say you're sorry I
don't buy that you're sorry
like how will you think I'm you're
supposed to accept an apology of you
staring at [ __ ] Apple TV look at me
you know what I have to say I'm not
singing in the chauvinistic way but it's
kind of like if I was cutter I might be
like guy sexy we had sex after I was
like oh she's kind of feisty and I was
like I'm still gonna have sex with you
after this but you have to look at me
and apologize like I was like and then I
did the whole thing we're like here look
look at me and pretend I did something
kind of [ __ ] up to you and I'm gonna
look at the TV and just be like sorry
cutter alright I'm sorry I was like do
you feel apologized to now does he do
learn from that so the next time he's
late he looks at you and goes hey I'm
sorry he's called me so much from work
today so I think so so this happened
recently last night this was last night
and he freaked out and then and then
beau pissed you off this morning yes so
you've had a rough morning and even
podcast no I would what do you mean this
is like witching hour afternoon with
both my kids I'm so happy to be here
right yeah this is therapy too isn't it
I love seeing you I love seeing you it's
really great seeing you it is great
seeing you it is you have a podcast I've
- okay that that wasn't in my notes well
I have momma said which is it's a year
old I do it with my friend Jenna and
it's just all about like the ups and
downs of parenting I'm not just mom do
we just have Bob Saget's our guest this
week they realize he is a potty mouth
he was [ __ ] awesome I mean he is
equal part
dirty-ass comic and like so reflective
and kind very smart very smart there's a
wonderful guest so that I have mama said
and then I have my newer baby podcast
called pajama pants that I do with
robber Tyler who played my brother on
Sopranos and our friend Kassim and
that's new and that's new we're like 21
episode 22 episodes in we just had dr.
drool on though which was kind of cool
doctors you be perfect for the show
three or four times and I can't get the
[ __ ] I don't know how you touches him
he knows somebody the email I don't know
how we he drove all the way to our like
our garage studio and like Silverlake
all the way in the east side like so if
we can get him you can get him it was an
amazing yes great he took I remember
when I was doing love line stuff I like
hey is it true it's like right after sex
if you pee probably won't get a disease
he's like that's [ __ ] why you
talking he didn't say [ __ ] baby loves
EMDR by the way I thought I was doing
and he was so stoked good but you know
Rob is people just think like he like
they haven't heard from him in a while
but rob has been sober for almost seven
years I mean but he had a major drinking
problem and then opioid and benzo
addiction and he kicked it and he's
wonderful and then Kassim had some
drinking issues and then there's me so
like were three very different people
that we just talked about everything I
think yes but wait what kind of sparked
this was they were like can you ask your
friend by the way you didn't text me
back
they snow they're like can you have your
friend ask your friend Michael Rosenbaum
I was like yeah I texted you and you
didn't write me back
you're a liar right now call me up it
was another song I made it I just got
your text from an hour ago but alright
well then I did texture maybe not about
that what was your question was will you
come on our pocket babe long time no
speak so Rob liar I learn I'll ER he
played my brother in Sopranos lives here
now we were doing a podcast together as
well but he mentioned to me that he
loves yours if you ever want him on I'm
happy to introduce you guys and then
yesterday I said see you tomorrow man
mhm so I I didn't respond yes I thought
I didn't come here cuz he's like
freakishly allergic to dogs but I I
really
of course I wanted to do this I thought
I responded I mean of course I do your
pockets I'll be on tomorrow okay well
we'll figure it out you know he'll come
on so yes I have pajama pants and it's
so fun drama pants we talk about all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] do you love it I
love it isn't it cool it is cool it's a
really I look forward to that like it
doesn't
I have zero expectations when I go into
either of them do you know what I mean
it's not about a result when you podcast
it's like so nice to have conversation
and and edited because I always say to
write I go I don't say I don't talk
about and I always just start talking
listen this is what you and I would have
talked about if we sat down for lunch
probably a million percent so that's
what people get listen in an intimate
conversation yes almost exactly this is
not any different no then you know yes
isn't that crazy
yeah I do I there's something about it
that to me is just honest and innocent
and pure and just cool and people
actually listen you know like dude this
touched my life the interview with Jimmy
Lin opening up about her life and MS and
this and just like oh my god gave me
hope and I only listen to podcast in my
car I never acting if somebody says
you're gonna make a ton of money doing
this podcast that I need your full time
no oh no like what's a ton of money hmm
couple million dollars a year yeah I'll
give you a million dollar but I can't
know a million cash but you can act I
still want to enjoy my life yeah but oh
so acting you enjoy it yes usually the
long hours
um I don't mind it well I think it's
more if I'm I hmm I really want a job in
LA you know what I want I want to be in
a [ __ ] stay calm for the next few
years just because my kids are little
isn't that the dream job do you like
multicam stuff no why Jassi just that I
hate to say this because I want to sound
like it
I've done it before yeah I just think
it's it's not the most deep it's where
you know I just think it's people love
it so what do I know big think there is
a huge hit
millions of people love it they make
millions of what is my opinion matter my
opinion is I just it's like what is it
am i doing that's what right no a little
substance I don't do acting still yeah I
mean I am but I'm directly yeah I'm
working on stuff and I I went through
stuff I told you the treatment thing I
was not feeling well I had neck surgery
so now I'm getting in a stronger place
and I'm working on that I'm figuring out
what what I want to be so laser stuff
done yeah stuff because this show that I
wrote and I just got a great show runner
who's really amazing I can't say
anything but we're gonna start pitching
that I got an animated series that were
pitching and so there's a lot of things
that I'm doing and I like creating you
know but I do
I do love acting if it could be just
like hey uh so you're just gonna act
from 12:00 to 4:00 today that's why I
love sitcoms
well here's the thing sitcom though
you're doing in front of a live studio
audience and that that's me that's too
much Nerva it's nerve-wracking [ __ ] it
scares me man I used to I used to love
it but now I don't know if I used to
love it there's just something I like
the you're right it's the easiest
schedule if that's how your mind works I
can be home for bedtime every night
except for mom yeah but Bo would [ __ ]
love it come to so many great sitcoms
are there any more not many how many I
have not I don't know I don't watch TV
hardly where are they like multicam yeah
I don't know what they are what your
mother was that people like that well
it's that the council yeah that's been
down for a while okay yeah just finished
two Big Bang Theory scares the [ __ ] out
of me those guys these hear what he's
memorizing every week his muscle is
stronger than I am he's got that muscle
he's got that lucky let's go drives me
up a [ __ ] wall alright well you and I
will
your heart attack a heart attack I have
so much fun yeah but I'd rather do like
a horror movie and you're there for
three months I'd rather do like a you
know what else eh uh yeah that's me what
do you want a half hour like the one I
wrote something that's like hey let's go
shoot this for three four months single
time for the rest of the year you want a
streaming yeah Netflix episodes episode
you bust my ass know all the stuff
before I get there I mean just do this
and then boom what the that's the dream
love it putting it out there I'm just
saying that's what I'd love to do it
like that's I was on that show and
Pasteur was great I was so great job it
was great thank you and I loved it and I
love the people I just I got canceled
out for two seasons and that would've
been a great shot I would've done for
six years so yes yeah you know yeah but
like when you get older it just it's
harder to do certain things I'm you know
I'm getting on close to 50 like at one
hour when people are say hey will you do
a one-hour drama 22 episodes a year
that's a big commitment I just I just
don't want to do it and look again if I
had to feed a [ __ ] family I'm a
single loser here if I had a family if I
had I do support some of my family but
if I had to work like like that I would
do anything there's nothing I wouldn't
do if I had to work yeah I would work at
McDonald's I've worked at McDonald's I
worked at a go-kart place I was a
mechanic at a go-kart track McCann in
college I worked at a roller rink I was
the DJ at a roller rink I work at a
grocery store the McDonald's I were I
worked at a telemarketing place all the
incarnations Michael Rosen my job yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm look I'm lucky I'd
like to we're gonna I was talking about
the podcast if I may if I can yeah then
I'd love to just sit in this room all
day and just talk to people who are more
interesting like you you know not more
interesting why you're interesting kind
of are you always this into Ryan I know
actually not this is the most I talked
to - yeah this is the most you've talked
since that's what it is
I think it is we exciting about bingo
night tomorrow night very excited I'm
more excited about tacos I love
oh yeah I'm having a taco truck I told
my friends I said listen here's the deal
I said fifteen bucks all you could eat
tacos and includes everything in my
clean up and all that [ __ ]
bring an extra five bucks for bingo
night we got 30 people coming we're
gonna big games of bingo for real money
about a really expensive bingo this is
life
cell phones podcasts bingo I'm with you
look I just want to you know what it is
I want to do things because I really
want to have fun and I know I'm gonna
have fun doing them if there's an
element of fun in there I'll do it I
don't care if I make money or not if
it's fun do you do game nights anymore
um I haven't done a game night where we
have art night people come over and draw
and stuff I'm not good but it doesn't
matter it's not about being great it's
about being in the moment Wow you know
we're gonna do here no I mean there's so
many things here you know my therapist
called about you know she goes she says
you're always should [ __ ] you [ __ ]
on yourself you're always [ __ ] on
yourself rosenbaum [ __ ] like should
i I don't know should I do that should I
do that D [ __ ] on yourself my dad the
one piece of advice that always rings in
my head from my dad is always limit your
shoulda woulda couldas so no I don't
should have all the time I end up like
taking chances and do it mm-hmm I like
that about you um you do strength
training to stay strong I do there's a
strength training really helped with the
MS yeah I love feeling strong while ice
my person might have mobility issues
still a little bit or balance issues I I
like seeing muscles on my body does that
help pain go away the strength of a
campaign you don't have pain you just
have like lack of control sometimes if
certain things your body does yep so no
pain look you know what maybe if
somebody else was in my body they think
this was painful
I don't you baffle me woman you baffle
me because I mean I know you say
everybody would be this strong but
you're just you know it is I think
you're just so beautiful inside and out
see how you said thank you no no look at
me I'm not so nice thank you I do I mean
it because I look at you and it's it's
you are you're just you are I know you
say you have anger issues I know you say
you have things that you need to work on
you
EMDR and you're working in yourself
you're trying to be the best you can you
want to feel the best you can be and
that's the whole game right that's the
that's what you have to do mm-hmm but
also to have that attitude III think
that maybe that's your parents or some
animal cuz your soul has some really
good friends you know for my 36th
birthday uh I came home to find all my
friends in my backyard sitting in a
circle unlike blankets and they
literally went around a circle to tell
me how they felt about me oh my god it
was the most magical moment still to
this day of my life and all of it
basically at the end it was they all
just were like we wish you could see
yourself the way we see you and that's
what I try I mean I'm still not there
trust me but like that's I was even
thinking that as you're telling me this
I was like I wish I could digest what
he's saying to me right now and believe
it wholeheartedly but um maybe as humans
we we were not wired to really do that
or some people can and it's amazing I
just I I try to I appreciate what you're
saying I wish I could believe it about
myself for sure do you love yourself um
you know it's like I think about like
what my legacy would be for my kids and
I think that they would always say like
she was always she always tried her best
and I think that's like all anyone can
do right so I guess I love myself for
that I'm hard on myself I'm hard on
myself every day I mean I I'm I'm I'm
very I'm good at like separating I
understand what's my ego and what's not
my egos very mean to me and so I've been
dealing with that my whole life and I
have the awareness now it still sucks
but um that's why I'm like you know I'm
working on it I'm figured trying but
like you're crying
I don't want to make you sad gonna be
happy you know what else really is holy
is
weed weed mm-hmm is what we yeah because
yeah like every night like it's my I
didn't I didn't smoke we tell us 34
another big weed smoker either but I was
at IVA or is it independence in the time
of day
I don't smoke during a day with I'm with
my kids do you have a certain branders
or something that I really like Lowell
Farms okay they make these videos they
make mini joints so it's like just you
know a little bit for me they also have
these hemp ones that don't get you high
but I get so [ __ ] creative on them oh
okay hang on a second will you write
this down up Jack I'll bring you a pack
next time I see you ya know why I am
teared up here why because I thought you
know I imagined I tried it
what you said was so profound how
beautiful is it that your friend sat you
yeah
sat with you around you telling you all
the reasons you should love yourself the
things that you don't see and I have a
feeling like I I feel like you and I are
similar like that I just like I don't
think I'm not great
I really don't no matter how much I say
oh yeah I'm gonna do charity and I'm
going to do this I could sit there and
say all these things and I do and I
really am trying to be better and I'm
trying to be a good person I'm trying it
for me right but I don't know if I I
wish everyone could have what I had that
night I think if everyone can have that
at least once in their adult life it was
you know it was cool to as my son sat
there and watched it all did you cry oh
I was a [ __ ] mess anybody else cried
everyone did cutter cry yeah I think he
did he's not an easy crier but but I
think he did he's not like Jon Jon Cryer
is Jon Cryer no just you know I always
say things like oh I'm gonna go I got a
Christian Bale I gotta get out of here
god what a Jon Cryer use names or as
verbs I like that Oh what was the one
that you remember the most when someone
was sitting there in your backyard that
night and telling you I could see you
know it what was the one that was in a
Mickey who's not like emotional like
doesn't cry she's like the party girl
she's like the fun
all right and she looked at me and she's
like I know that you opted out of so
many things because you think you're
gonna slow us down and she's like but if
you could only know that it's like an
honor to hold you up like it would be an
honor to give you a piggy back at
Coachella or a belay or a stagecoach
like you always say like I'm not gonna
go I don't want to slow you guys down
and it's the truth and she's like it
would literally nothing would make me
happier than to throw you on my back and
have you experience that with me and
that really hit me and I just home that
is so sweet
it was so sweet so sweet I have a really
good friends I might have embedded all
these tears that are come down I mean I
cry every once in a while but well it's
not just about me it's just about like
really great humans that like you know
took their time that night and I don't
know I think that's I think that's
beautiful I think everybody should do
that what they didn't intend to do that
they thought they were just gonna sit
around we thought we were gonna do like
I met my friend Ryan who's like this
he's just like God to me he's like
changed my life the day I met him he's
like kind of like a life coach waking up
with Ryan follow him he's the greatest
human he was gonna leave like a
meditation and he said he's like I'm
just gonna begin by telling Jamie what
she means to me and then somebody else
went like oh I want to tell her and then
that's what it turned into so I think
what also it wasn't like a forced
situation like everybody think of what
you're gonna say to Jamie
so everything was like just like quick
like people would just be like oh I want
to say this to you so it was just a very
inspired moment it was happened very
naturally because I would be horrified
if people were like we're all gonna sit
around and tell you how we love you I'd
be like oh my god no no no I'd rather
get you stoned and let's eat a Ralph's
cake and like just like rolls you know
old school
oh so look I think that's a beautiful
thing so if you're listening I mean if
you mean I think that's important what
would you do if you know on your
birthday or something everybody just
kind of sat around say hey man
help your close friend said I want you
to know this about you and just opened
up a more vulnerable about you I would
say you're full of [ __ ]
no I mean there'll be really nice I mean
that sounds like I don't
no when I would do that but do you love
yourself not all the time now you like
yourself you I like myself fine no all
right all you could do is work on
yourself all you can do is every day
just take a step in the right direction
all you could do is say [ __ ] up
yesterday today I'm gonna do this try
your best you know what I didn't like
how I talked apologize you know I didn't
like her you know say something you know
what I want this you know it's not about
you right now it's about them
you know yesterday Jess was sick my
assistant Jess for two days and you know
sometimes I'm a little helpless but you
know there's pot caps going on and
there's dogs running around there's
people fixing [ __ ] and there's like I'm
juggling I managed but all I could think
about was like texting her hey how you
feeling that's so good
how are you feeling I'm so glad I'm sure
part of me was like going hey are you
are you better yet I need you to be
better
but the reality was I really wanted her
to feel better I did and if she was gone
for the rest of the week I would manage
that's all the work the shines putting
it back out
sure I mean sure I mean it's just like
you're [ __ ] sick when I'm sick you're
there I mean you know all right this is
called shit-talking this is it should
talk in with Rosenbaum this is just some
questions there's not many you could
answer them quickly don't have a rap
this is from all my lovely patrons on
patreon they're fantastic and they get
to ask these questions okay Meghan how
was it appearing in a Lonely Island
music video oh so fun I had no it was
like so out of the blue and I had no
idea what I was going into jizz in my
pants it took me a second yeah
cash or credit Sophie do you have a
dream Broadway role you would love to
play uh well it was Eponine and Leamas
but I think I'm too old so maybe Fantine
Fontaine's the lead no she dies like 1/4
the way through that's the lead good
Drew Barrymore and scream and Hathaway
did win the Oscar for Fantine mm-hmm
what was that song she sang I dream do I
cry when she's saying that that's so
emotional Rose mommy wrap okay I dream
good Rick no Danny Danny
I see there are now Sopranos conventions
happening with jamie-lynn Sigler ever be
interested in attending one it's nothing
I was like I'll be interested or not I
was working when they had this first
Sopranos con I it just feels so weird if
it feels very removed from what the show
was like it being like this like
critically acclaimed like beautiful
piece of art like not to save it like
Comic Con and these things are like not
honoring like great great work it just
doesn't it's for you it doesn't compute
mm-hmm I get you I just think that for
me it's like it's a chance for people
that never meet you but we just have a
blast and hear how much they love you
just very uncomfortable against like me
being like I don't give a [ __ ] about
this respect that a hundred percent some
people just not yeah I don't need to be
paid to be like like a spectacle and
like wave like that feels awkward to me
sure leads to ask at this point in her
life is that mass a major part of how
she sees herself or is it just a piece
of the puzzle that is jamie-lynn Sigler
it's is it's definitely a major part and
it's what I'm trying to figure out how
to have it not be it's impossible to not
have it not be right now but I'm trying
to have it not be Raj my wife and I
dealt with some negativity from friends
and family after we decided to stop
breastfeeding our son because of health
issues she was dealing with I remember
you being more vocal about having to
stop breastfeeding because of the need
to get back on medication for MS what is
your advice for current and potential
moms dealing with the stigma of feeling
as if you're supposed to breastfeed your
child as long as possible look to Amy
Schumer she just like put something out
about how she was like you know what
this is not feeling right for me and
it's not right for my family so I'm
gonna stop and like god oh she's just so
[ __ ] awesome because like this is her
first rodeo and she had the wherewithal
and like the self-love and awareness to
be like nah not for me and my babies all
right and I'm not gonna feel bad about
it like you and all this like guilt is
has nothing to do with all the other
chatter it's all on you and so if you're
that baby is a good baby so you know
you've got two things for me
you're gonna give me your dope um what
is it your dope the lols yeah I need to
know what you're using and I'm gonna
come on your podcast great podcast is
called again pajama pants pajama pants
is the one that's 21 episodes in and
you're having a blast doing it and that
dr. drew on Bob Saget said so you could
listen to both her podcast look if you
love her like I do you're gonna love her
after this interview listen to her stuff
man subscribe and you know support men
these folks here who subscribe they're
so loyal they really are just awesome
that's why do you call them things are
they like well you know usually I try to
respond as much as I can it's hard but
you know the the patreon thing that that
I'm part of now it's easier to just kind
of like oh hey you know and and I guess
you have a name for them like you're
like rose and bombs yeah the bomb squad
the bomb squad just came up with that do
you guys like the bomb squad or maybe
Rosie's Rosen's Rosie's
roses roses try to top it you did in a
row squad I can't look any better you
were a frickin delight I thank you for
mom to be inside of you anytime I hope
you guys loved that as much as I did
inspirational yes that was a tear could
you see the tear down my eye let me know
real quick shout out to my top tier
patrons here we go
Alison Andrew Angelina Barry Bob board
tags Chris Dion Emily Emily Jason Jason
Jason Jason you're both important Jerry
Jill Trisha you he go Kevin Kristen
Lauren Lee hi Lee
she's obsessed I didn't miss her name
I'm Carla mark with a C Michael
Nancy I love my Nancy Andy Cohen ROG I
just saw talked tirage Robert Samantha
Sarah Scott Sean Tiana you guys I hope
you're enjoying the podcast I am you see
that the patrons on there they get a
certain tea
you get to ask questions at the end for
every guest so join patreon join me join
the revolution
I'm really excited and make sure was it
a Bernie impression huh that was join
the revolution
I don't even is that sound like him I
don't I thought that's that you're
trying I don't even know is that what he
says maybe look uh whatever what else
that's pretty much it you know thanks
for listening to the stage at last week
Miami may 9th remember Smallville nights
and signing autographs and also in st.
Louis at the Wizard World June 5th of
Smallville nights as well get your
tickets while they last all that stuff I
want to say thank you Ryan again because
you know I know how hard this video
thing is because we're not if you guys
notice we're not just doing the I'm not
saying it's cheap but it's [ __ ] cheap
it's easy to put the top and the to one
screen and I just run it it's easy Ryan
could do that in an hour
correct yeah doesn't edit it whatever he
edits this so we're going back and forth
it's an interview it's like you're
getting inside I think it's great I hope
we continue to do it he's gonna start
working on ways to make it faster but
you're getting great at it so yeah I
hope you continue it's a skill I head
and I said I could do it not you did
yeah was not lying
whoo you're not resenting me right no
not at all you tell me when you're
starting to resent me yeah I mean I you
know I I just want you know I always
want people to be happy I think it's a
problem of mine but it's also a good
thing like I you know I want Ryan to go
I love working on the show I know that
if Michael if this blows up or if
Michael gets something else he's gonna
bring me along or consider me right I'd
like to be considered sure I always
would consider you honestly I am for
your consideration I absolutely adore
you and the music you're listening to
underneath is just Ryan and I playing a
little guitar so we haven't even put
this music under it yet but when you're
listening to it see now it's playing but
we haven't even Dennis we have no idea
what we're going to do but we're gonna
do it thank you guys so much
make sure you subscribe please to
YouTube hit the notification thing
subscribe spread the word
let's get those numbers up help me get
the numbers up on audio and video and
below this sucker up
working in another live podcast
potentially in Phoenix tell me who else
who's out there in Phoenix right in a
hello at inside of podcast comm I
believe is for fan letters followed me
on the handles the at inside a podcast
on Twitter and then add inside a pod on
an Instagram all that stuff thanks so
much for all your encouragement your
letters your it might you hear that what
I don't want to be that guy we were
that's the worst sound ever in fact
people listening him that's it I'm done
gross bomb [ __ ] off we've got so many
great guests ahead of you a head now
like believe me the stories get better
and better we I got someone that's
coming up that it was a really tough
grab and a really tough episode for you
to to edit because it's an hour and a
half hour and a half but it is gold it
is gold and it's a big actor who
everyone loves if you haven't seen the
show I'm not gonna tell you anymore
I can't talk about anyone I'm not gonna
do it but if you're in patreon you'll
learn mm-hmm all right guys thank you
from Ryan taya's and myself thank you
for us allowing us to both be inside of
you and I hope you have a wonderful
wonderful rest of your week and spread
the word for the podcast and be healthy
be grateful be happy and do your best
man swell I'm trying to do
it's called life it's not called winning
wait I'm gonna come up with the worst
quotes after every episode from now on
so that's it I'm not going to think it's
not called life for a reason yeah so
it's not call waiting
bugs [ __ ] worsted whatever all right
I'm ending with that carve them into
some wood and just hang them above your
sink could you yeah somebody out there's
gonna go I remember a shitty quote from
the week before and amaura one hey
remember guys like if you think about it
if you just say something without
thinking that's what the code has to be
you know guys they never said life was
easy
they just said it was wrong if you're
lucky
how's that that's good it's like it's
like a mash up of several different
antigens it's too long I'm gonna [ __ ]
off now thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you good day
[Music]